-♪♪ Mad Lib Theater,
ah-ahh, yeah ♪♪
-Now, here's how it works.
I'm going to ask you...
-Here's how it works.
-...some silly words.
-Pretend you're in the back
of a 1976 station wagon.
-Yes. Exactly like that. And you
get that little flip thing.
I'm gonna ask silly words,
nouns, verbs, adjectives.
As we do that, they're going to
be written onto cue cards.
-This is going to be a real test
of my education.
-And we're going to act out
a dramatic Mad Libs scene.
All right. Ready for this?
-Yes, sir.
-Here we go. Name of
a famous cartoon character?
-Popeye.
-Type of car?
-A Pinto. Pinto. A Pinto.
-Pinto, Pinto, Pinto.
Okay, perfect.
-Yeah, three or four of 'em.
-Yeah, yeah.
Type of food?
-A lamb Shank.
-[ Laughs ]
This is fun.
A place you go for fun?
-K-- Uh, kayaking!
Is there a wrong answer?
-No, but kayaking
isn't a place for fun.
-I go to Hydra, to Greece.
Yeah.
-You go to Greece for fun?
-Sure.
In my fantasy --
In my wild fantasy life.
-You're going to go to Greece
for kayaking.
-Do you mean like to --
I go to Greece.
-Yeah, Greece for kayaking.
-Yeah.
Mode of transportation?
-Uh, on a Vespa.
-Oh, nice. I thought you
were going to say kayaking.
[ Laughter ]
Chain restaurant?
-Bob's Big Boy.
-Nice!
-Or Frisch's Big Boy
in Cincinnati.
But that's cool. That's cool.
-I'm just -- I'm thinking
about the cue cards.
I was writing it down.
Type of relative?
-Granny. Auntie. Grandma.
-Grandma Auntie.
Okay, good.
-Grandma Auntie!
-Famous singer?
-Pete Seeger!
[ Laughs ] Pete Seeger?
Yeah, I love him.
What you would shout
when you walk into your
own surprise party?
-Oh, I did this.
"I should've washed my hair."
-Oh, nice.
-That's what I did,
when I was 16.
-"I should've washed my hair."
-Someone threw me a party.
"I should've washed my hair."
-That's a great line.
Type of profession?
-Astronaut.
A verb ending in I-N-G?
-Digging.
-I'm digging.
-Plural objects?
-Uh, b-- bikinis. Bikinis.
-Bikinis.
-I was going to say pens,
but that's boring.
-No, bikinis is perfect.
Bikinis.
A country?
-France.
-A number?
-52.
Or nipples grew.
Or wait. What was that?
What was that?
[ Laughter ]
-Adjective?
-Uh, uh. Untrustworthy.
-Untrustworthy.
Oh, that was beautiful.
-Ooh.
-Plural animal?
-Rhinos.
-What you would shout
if you got a stain
on a very expensive shirt?
-[Bleep] Dagnabbit!
-Dagnabbit. I love it.
A plural body part?
-Ears.
Another adjective?
-Flashy. Flashy.
-Flashy.
Two words that rhyme?
-Um...
Yeah, I'm gonna go
"spies" and "eyes."
-Spies and eyes. Very good.
-Or I could do
"spies" and "despise."
-No, spies and eyes are great.
And the last one -- a noun?
-Uh, deodorant. Deodorant.
-Deodorant.
-Yeah, deodorant.
-Deodorant. Very good.
We've filled out
the words for our scene.
-Thrilling!
You guys seem riveted.
-Are you ready to perform?
-Yes. Of course, of course.
-All right. Let's go.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
♪♪♪♪
Ohh. I'm sure having
a great night.
This is a great -- great time
on this date tonight, Popeye.
-I'm having fun, as well, Pinto.
Did you enjoy your lamb shank?
-Yes, I did.
-Great.
So, uh, tell me a little
about yourself.
-Oh. Okay. Well...
Um, I grew up in
a small town in Greece.
For kayaking.
-Yeah.
-And, um -- But I hated it.
Most people do, which is why you
don't hear about that a lot.
And then I just decided
to pack up and buy a Vespa
and just move to Bob's Big Boy.
-Right.
-That's where my Grandma Auntie
Pete Seeger lives.
Grandma Auntie lives
at Bob's Big Boy, yeah.
-Oh, my God!
-Yeah.
-[ Laughing ]
I should've washed my hair!
-Yeah. Oh, well.
-Well -- Well,
how about you, Popeye?
What do you do for a living?
-I'm a very successful
astronaut.
-Ohh.
-But my real passion is digging.
[ Laughter ]
Just give me a spoon and
put me out in the backyard.
-Oh, my God.
Wh-- Popeye, that's my
favorite activity, too!
-What do you like to do for fun?
-I just said I like digging.
-Yeah. I was listening, yeah.
-Well, I --
-What else?
-I enjoy collecting bikinis.
-Oh, yeah.
-I think you know
what that means.
And taking long walks to France.
-Is that right?
That's a lot of steps
on your Fitbit.
Listen. Pinto, there's something
I have to tell you.
-Did we eat our bread already?
-Oh, yeah.
We're done with dinner.
-Oh, we're done.
-We're finished
with dinner, yeah.
-Oh, yes. I said that earlier.
-Check please!
Getting the check.
But it's going well.
I have something to tell you.
-Okay. God, I'm nervous.
What is it?
-Okay. [ Clears throat ]
Here goes nothing.
-Yeah?
-I live with
52 untrustworthy rhinos.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh [bleep].
Aw, dagnabbit!
-I understand your reaction.
A lot of people
respond that way.
-No. No. I'm just glad
you're being honest.
You know,
I really like you, Popeye.
-Yeah.
-And it's not just 'cause
you have nice ears.
-This feels right.
-Yeah.
Hey, listen.
Valentine's Day is almost here.
Do you mind if I, um,
if I recite my favorite
Valentine's poem?
-Oh, my goodness.
I would love to hear it.
-Oh, thank you.
-Yes, please.
Okay.
-You're gonna stand up.
-I'm gonna stand up
and face you.
I hope the other diners
don't mind.
-I'm happy there's no one else
at the restaurant.
Picked a great...
I don't know how we got
a reservation here, yeah.
All right. Yes. Go ahead.
-Okay.
Roses are flashy...
violets are spies...
deodorant is sweet...
and so are eyes.
-[ Laughs ]
That is beautiful.
And...scene.
There you go right there.
Fantastic.
My thanks to
Sarah Jessica Parker!